من مقر رسمي للرئيس ونوابه ومضافه للرؤساء
الاجانب تحول القصر الجمهوري الجديد في
السودان الى بؤره رئيسيه للصراع فالقصر
الجمهوري باتا اكثر النقاط اشتعالا الى
جانب محيط القياده العامه للجيش وطبعا
مطار الخرطوم القصر مقره العاصمه الخرطوم
ويتكون من ثلاثه طوابق من يسيطر فعليا
عليه واين تدور الاشتباكات هناك حقيقه
يتجاذب طرفاء الصراع للسيطره على الاقل
اعلاميا قوات الدعم السريع اعلنت سيطرتها
على هذا القصر قبل اسبوعين لكن الجيش خرج
مرارا لينفي ما وصفه بالمعلومات المضلله
والكاذبه غير ان قوات الدعم السريع نشرت
فيديو لعناصرها من داخل القصر مؤكده بسط
سيطرتها عليه واحتفاظها بمواقع استراتيجيه
اخرى بينها مطار الخرطوم حاليا الاشتباكات
لا تزال
في محيط القصر بين الطرفين لكنها تخطت
المواجهات بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني فالاخير استخدم قوات بل استخدم
قوات الشرطه الاحتياطيه من كافه الولايات
وهي ما وصفتها قوات الدعم السريع بالقوه
المقاتله المعاديه وفي وقت يحاول الجيش
وقوات الاحتياط التقدم نحو القصر تحت غطاء
جوي كما نتابع في هذه الصوره تتصدق قوات
الدعم باسلحه رشاشه ومضادات الطيران
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات